von den pagoden maß für den hochhäusern
singapurs von den ehemaligen
schlachtfeldern kambodschas ins
pulsierende jakarta
640 millionen menschen darunter muslime
christen buddhisten und taoisten und
konfusion ist in thailand malaysia die
philippinen und vietnam asian gehört zu
den komplexesten regionen der welt
es ist unglaublich vielfältig bietet so
viel potenzial für handel und
verbundenheit die wirtschaft von asian
ist insgesamt so groß wie die indians
die chancen sind gewaltig ebenso jedoch
die herausforderungen
grenzen verlieren gerade in dieser
region an bedeutung
südostasien steht am scheideweg
eine aufstrebende wirtschaftsmacht der
in zukunft von wichtigen entscheidungen
abhängt die die gesamte nächste
generation in asien prägen werden
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo ich bin hess länder armin unsere
reise beginnt in thailand wo asian vor
über 50 jahren entstand
fünf länder die sich zum schutz vor dem
kommunistischen china verbündeten
seitdem hat sich viel geändert
vietnam myanmar und kambodscha sind in
schwierigen zeiten beigetreten die
wirtschaftsleistung der region wächst
seit zehn jahren jedes jahr um 5
die größte errungenschaft war es die
vielfältigste region des planeten zu
vereinen
640 millionen menschen darunter muslime
christen buddhisten
maoisten und konfusion ist
frieden und wohlstand zu erwirken wirkte
nirgends unwahrscheinlicher als
[Musik]
wir sind weit gekommen darunter bleibe
ich optimistisch die schwarzmaler sagt
natürlich es gehe nichts voran oder
nicht weit genug
aber wenn man sich erreger den personen
und güterverkehr sowie den handel
innerhalb von asian ansieht sieht man
große fortschritte
darum bin ich sehr optimistisch
die finanzbranche ist nicht in allen
ländern gleich ausgereift es
unterscheidet sich den rahmenbedingungen
entsprechend
für grenzübergreifende finanzintegration
werden wir wohl einiges standardisieren
müssen
wir müssen nicht alle auf den gleichen
standard kommen aber die standards der
länder müssen für grenzüberschreitende
geschäfte miteinander kompatibel sein
[Musik]
ich bin in thailand das ist mir einmal
und dort ist laos unter uns der mächtige
mekong der bis nach vietnam fließt diese
region bekannt für den opiumhandel ist
nur ein kleines puzzleteil von asian
die zehn mitgliedstaaten unterscheiden
sich drastisch
von indonesien mit der größten
muslimischen bevölkerung der welt bis
zum kleinen brunner die politische und
religiöse vielfalt ist gewaltig die 640
millionen bewohner von asien stellen
neun prozent der weltbevölkerung
die wirtschaftsleistung von 2,8
billionen dollar ist ebenso groß wie die
von frankreich großbritannien oder
indien
[Musik]
es gibt hier sehr reiche länder wie
singapur und brunei
aber auch arme länder wie laos und
kambodscha
sie gehören derselben organisation an
große länder wie indonesien mit 270
millionen einwohnern und singapur mit
fünf millionen
somit ergänzen sich die länder von asian
aufgrund der kosten durch zölle und der
transport geschwindigkeit ist die
vereinigung noch nicht abgeschlossen
sie muss hier schnell aufholen sonst
werden china und indien den
online-handel und die handelswege
dominieren
scheint es manchmal die länder asiens
würden mehr miteinander konkurrieren als
kooperieren
die frage stellt sich durchaus wollen
sie es zu bejahen
man sieht das auch in china dort
konkurrieren die provinzen manchmal
untereinander bei asian findet es auf
nationaler ebene statt und es daher noch
intensiver
ein meilenstein der starken gruppe war
2015 die einrichtungen der asian
wirtschaftsgemeinschaft asien
ziel der es ist ein einheitlicher markt
der sich in die weltwirtschaft einfügt
für den warenhandel ist es quasi ein
einziger markt
es gibt aber noch finanzielle hürden die
wir überwinden müssen
ich arbeite seit über 20 jahren in der
asse und den verhandlungen dieses
abkommens
wenn ich mir die errungenschaften aus
diesen 20 jahren ansehe bin ich doch
sehr zufrieden damit
der unterschied ist die sichtweise ist
das glas halb leer oder halb voll ich
würde sagen im vergleich zu unserem
ausgangspunkt ist es halb voll
ich hätte gerne einen einheitlichen
markt und bewegungsfreiheit für
arbeitskräfte was für zehn jahre
vielleicht etwas zu viel verlangt ist
wenn wir aber den einheitlichen markt
haben warum sollte nicht eher
jahrhundert prozent aller airlines in
asien besitzen
sie an sollte seinen bürgern auf
vielerlei art nutzen
finanzintegration
wirtschaftsintegration
handels integration
das ziel ist eine einheitliche politik
wirtschaftlicher nachhaltigkeit
grenzen verlieren gerade in dieser
region an bedeutung
zu dieser jahreszeit sind weite gebiete
im norden thailands myanmar und laos von
rauch verhüllte
landwirte brenne nach der ernte ihre
felder ab der ertrag wird in kleinen
betrieben wie diesen verpackt
kleinunternehmen den anschluss zur
vierten industriellen revolution zu
ermöglichen ist eine der größten
herausforderungen von asian die kosten
von finanzdienstleistungen sinken durch
den tag und allgemeine technologie
drastisch
nicht nur können wir viel mehr menschen
bankdienstleistungen und versicherungen
ermöglichen sondern auch menschen in
entlegenen gebieten
darum sind smartphones so wichtig denn
sie verändern unsere
finanzdienstleistungen grundlegend
das ist das geniale an asian
asian ist die unvollkommen der
organisation der welt wenn man bei asian
genau hinsieht machen wir zwei schritte
nach vorn einen zurück und eine zur
seite wie eine krabbe die im kreis läuft
über jahrzehnte beobachtet wird asien
aber immer stärker und stärker ein grund
ist die flexibilität von asia unser
konsens prinzip leistet uns gute dienste
denn es ist sehr flexibel
es ist unvorstellbar dass 440 millionen
menschen in asien keine bankkonten haben
das ist unser nächstes thema bei asia
next generation
willkommen zurück in südostasien gibt es
viele kleine unternehmen wie diese in
manchen ländern stellen sie 90 prozent
aller arbeitsplätze
dennoch haben weiterhin gewaltige 440
millionen menschen kein bankkonto
das sind mehr menschen als die
bevölkerung der usa und deutschlands
zusammen
man will die banken lose bevölkerung
erschließen doch bisher ist das
schwierigste oft nur die menschen mit
schlechten bank zugang erreicht werden
warum
es geht um verschiedene dinge wenn es
darum geht die banken lose oder
unterversorgt die bevölkerung zu
erreichen muss es klare richtlinien für
die arten von produkten und bereichen
geben die wir bewerben möchten
in thailand ist die
haushaltsverschuldung hoch und manche
teile der bevölkerung sind ebenfalls
hoch verschuldet
darum brauchen wir find ick und
verantwortungsvollen umgang mit krediten
um bessere versorgung zu vernünftigen
preisen zu gewährleisten
mit neuen technologien die nicht mehr
probleme für sie erschaffen und ihre
finanzielle lage weiter die
stabilisieren
ich halte die kreditwürdigkeit und
garantie programme von rating agenturen
für eine mögliche lösung
wie wir kleinunternehmer unterstützen
und ihnen den zugang zu
finanzdienstleistungen ermöglichen
können
gleichzeitig halte ich digitale
finanzlösungen auch für eine möglichkeit
für kleinunternehmer am finanzwesen
teilzunehmen da die informationen hier
bei genauer sind und sie so zugang
erhalten könnten
die finanzielle inklusion ist nicht in
allen ländern gleich weit
fortgeschritten
in thailand entspricht die schwierigkeit
ein girokonto zu bekommen in etwa
normalen standards
bei auslandsüberweisungen haben wir
sorgen
die gebühren für auslandsüberweisungen
nach und aus thailand sind mit die
höchsten der welt
das wollen wir ändern und finn tech und
andere neue technologien können uns
dabei helfen mehr und mehr menschen am
markt teilhaben zu lassen
für händler in myanmar und reisbauern in
kambodscha für geschäfte in hanoi manila
und jakarta und bangkok eröffnet finther
eine völlig neue welt
doch geht es dabei immer wieder um die
gleichen kern thema nachhaltigkeit
verletzung und inklusion wie stellen sie
sicher dass länder wie kambodscha und
vietnam nicht abgehängt werden
zuallererst vietnam hat wirklich große
fortschritte gemacht
als das inklusiv groove programm begann
bekam in kambodscha laos und myanmar die
finanzierungshilfen für
infrastrukturprojekte zu günstigeren
konditionen
wir brauchen derartige praktische
initiativen
auch die ausbildung und umschulung die
gesamte berufsbildung wird so gefördert
das sind alles praktische maßnahmen
auch dass die kosten strukturell in
diesen ländern geringer sind als in
anderen asian staaten zieht seinerseits
investoren an
begrüßte die digitalisierung mit offenen
armen ist der rest der region ebenfalls
bereit für die vierte industrielle
revolution
wir sind etwas im rückstand aber wir
holen auf
mit der einzigartigen tech branche von
indonesien der verwendung von weiber in
den philippinen
bruder von laien in thailand und dem
wachsenden online-handel sowie der
wachsenden vernetzung durch
mobiltelefone und apps liegen wir nicht
mehr weit zurück
ich sage immer man muss groß denken
sie an muss in der technologiewelt groß
denken
unser rückstand ist nicht groß die
bildung muss noch aufholen und wir
müssen die menschen hier ausbilden um
unser humankapital richtig zu nutzen
ich glaube asien wird sich sehr schnell
anpassen sobald sich eine gelegenheit
dazu ergibt
ich denke wir können ein paar plätze
gutmachen wenn wir uns in einigen
bereichen anpassen
[Musik]
die integration benachbarter asian
länder ist ein wichtiger schritt der
2015 durch die es ihm möglich wurde
dadurch erhöhte sich das wachstum des
bruttoinlandprodukts erheblich er stieg
von 1200 dollar pro einwohner vor 20
jahren auf fast
4300 dollar
das ist für die finanzielle integration
sehr wichtig
wie schwierig wird die finanzintegration
dadurch dass sich die mitgliedstaaten in
sachen entwicklung so drastisch
unterscheiden
dadurch dass sie auf unterschiedlichen
entwicklungsstufen stehen ergänzend die
staaten einander einige staaten wie
singapur malaysia und thailand
erwirtschaften überschüsse während
andere länder geld brauchen so können
wir einander unterstützen und ergänzen
[Musik]
kann die produktivität aller asien
staaten verbessern
finanzsysteme in asien sind stark
verbesserungsfähig und technologie kann
hier eine große rolle spielen
inter kann die finanzielle inklusion
verbessern da die kosten für
finanzdienstleistungen drastisch sinken
werden
zehn länder mit eigenen kulturen
sprachen und religionen
alle auf anderen entwicklungsstufen
gibt es dennoch eine gemeinsame asien
identität
das werden wir als nächstes herausfinden
[Musik]
in den ersten 50 jahren ging es beim
projekt asian vornehmlich um die
verständigung der regierungen und ihre
zusammenarbeit jetzt geht es darum den
menschen von asien ein gefühl der
zugehörigkeit zu vermitteln es freut
mich dass asien hier die europäische
union nachahmt wie man in europa eine
eigene fahne sieht sieht man hier ebenso
die landesfahne unternehmen die fahne
von asian gibt es denn eine asian
identität in der frage herrscht keine
einigkeit
ich glaube nicht dass es so etwas gibt
und ich bin überzeugter asien ist warum
nicht es geht darum was asian seinen
einfachen bürgern bedeutet
wir müssen stärker an unserer marke
arbeiten zeigen dass asian jeden
einzelnen etwas angeht es wird wohl oft
eher als bedrohung denn als chance
wahrgenommen
in bezug auf die asian identität wird
viel unternommen gerade im
soziokulturellen bereich das ergänzt
sich mit der finanziellen und
wirtschaftlichen integration
mit wachsendem handel und zunehmenden
tourismus wird sich das wechselseitige
verständnis und die wertschätzung
innerhalb der asien gruppe stark
verbessern
gibt es eine asien identität
in vielerlei hinsicht ja wir mögen über
600 millionen menschen seien mit
verschiedenen sprachen kulturen und
identitäten
aber andererseits sind wir gleichzeitig
auch alle ein sehr gelassenes fall
das ist ein vorteil durch den wir besser
zusammenarbeiten können
es geht aber nicht nur um identität
sondern auch mobilität sie ist eine der
größten herausforderungen in asia arbeit
waren und geld müssen fließen über diese
grenze kommen die menschen aus myanmar
jeden tag nach thailand um zu arbeiten
und zu handeln aber in asien stellen
grenzen oft auch hindernisse für
geschäftsbeziehungen dar
[Musik]
in thailand gibt es über drei millionen
gastarbeiter aus myanmar ihr geld nach
myanmar zu schicken ist für sie sehr
teuer an der grenze wird auf den
naturalien gehandelt weil es so teuer
ist geld über die grenze hinweg in
andere länder zu senden und zu empfangen
intec kann hier helfen die finanzielle
inklusion deutlich zu verbessern
grenzen sind verarbeiter ein großes
problem wie können wir das problem lösen
und standardisieren
das ist ein heikles thema denn der freie
fluss von arbeitskraft steht letztlich
nicht zur debatte
nicht alle sind gleichermaßen bereit
menschen mit bestimmten qualifikationen
und angehörigen bestimmter berufe diese
mobilität zu gewähren
daran arbeiten wir die arbeitsmärkte
sind in ganz asien auf verschiedenen
entwicklungsstufen
wir müssen uns daher darauf
konzentrieren die verschiedenen
ökonomien zu integrieren durch den
handel mit waren sowie dienstleistungen
und durch investitionen
wenn wir in verschiedenen teilen von
asien wachstum schaffen können können
die menschen in allen ländern
angemessene gute arbeit haben
auf der anderen seite müssen wir mit den
zentralbanken zusammenarbeiten wobei wir
gute fortschritte bei der nutzung
lokaler währungen für handel und
investitionen sehen konnten
vor zwei jahren begannen die bank of
thailand und die bank negara malaysia
die nutzung von thailändischen baht und
malaysischen ringgit für handel und
investitionen zu fördern
seit letztem jahr ist die zentralbank
von indonesien als dritter partner dabei
dadurch nähern sich die wechselkurse der
währungen einander an somit haben
unternehmen in der region eine echte
wahl und die wechselkurse und gebühren
sie
in verschiedenen teilen von asien sieht
die zukunft heißt sie anders aus für die
großen unternehmen und großen städte
geht es nicht nur um den austausch über
asien grenzen hinweg sondern um den
globalen markt sich millionen kleine bis
mittlere unternehmen benötigen generell
zugang zu märkten
arbeiter suchen arbeit wo sie können
eltern suchen bildung für ihre kinder
das ist ein grund warum asien eine der
vielfältigsten und komplexesten regionen
der welt ist
was ist ihre vision für asien
wir hoffen dass asien weiter sicherheit
wohlstand und zufriedenheit bietet
das wir weiter jede woche das
wohlergehen der menschen in asien
verbessern können
die ganze arbeit für die wirtschaftliche
und finanzielle integration die
förderung von find ick unter gleichen
alles dient letztlich dem ziel das
wohlergehen der menschen in asien zu
verbessern
so wollen wir frieden und stabilität in
asien waren und zu frieden und wohlstand
auf der welt beitragen
wir sollten beachten was wir im westen
beobachten können
wenn der wohlstand in asien steigt
werden auch nachfrage und vielfalt
weiter wachsen
dadurch könnte sich die gesellschaft
spalten und soziale aspekte wie die
wohlstands verwaltung ein immer
wichtigeres thema werden
asien sollte sich bewusst werden was
unsere stärken und was unsere schwächen
sind
einige länder haben offensichtliche
spezialisierungen die sich von anderen
land unterscheiden singapur wird nie
eine große agrar nation aber es hat eine
sehr starke finanzinfrastruktur
die länder sollten also nicht
zwangsläufig andere imitieren sondern
ihre eigene nische finden
wirtschaftlich tut sich immer mehr es
gibt gemeinsame probleme die wir
bewältigen müssen und technologie wird
die grenzen zwischen den ländern
verschwimmen lassen
es geht also darum dass alle profitieren
und dass wir mit dem integrations
netzwerk von asian wachstum und
nachhaltigen wohlstand für alle bürger
in asien fördern
asien sollte vorsichtiger und
pragmatische vorgehen die arbeiter
ströme lenken
wenn ich mich nicht irre arbeiten
bereits millionen indonesia in malaysia
in singapur arbeiten 1,7 millionen
ausländer in diesem stadtstaat auf einer
insel
in thailand gibt es viele gastarbeiter
aus myanmar
arbeitskräfte sind ständig im fluss aber
eine echte bewegungsfreiheit wie in der
europäischen union ist nirgendwo in
sicht
mein traum für asien wäre ein
fortwährender zusammenhalt dass wir
nicht aufgrund der wachsenden rivalität
zwischen den usa und china zerbrechen
die sorge wie asian diesen gewaltigen
wettstreit zwischen den usa und china in
den kommenden zehn zwanzig jahren
überstehen kann bereitet mir schlaflose
nächte
von der quelle bis zum meer liegt der
mekong mehr als 4000 kilometer zurück
und ist seit jahrhunderten die
verbindende lebensader in diesem teil
der welt der wandel ist jedoch nicht
aufzuhalten
gewaltige infrastrukturprojekte und die
digitale revolution erschaffen eine
völlig neue zukunft
6 640 millionen menschen eine
wirtschaftsleistung vergleichbar mit
indien asian ist eine empor strebende
wirtschaftsmacht in ihrer mitte liegt
ein wachstums gigant
indonesien
wir sind noch im rückstand aber
gemeinsam mit indien sind hier die
größten volkswirtschaften hier und so
fortschritt wird globale folgen haben
17.000 inseln beherbergen die größte
muslimische bevölkerung der welt
vernetzung und inklusion stehen im
vordergrund
indonesien zeigt im kleinen was asian
ohne grenzen sein könnte in tunesien
muss die führung übernehmen marion zu
stärken und wirklich in den mittelpunkt
zu rücken
in indonesien gibt der online handel und
der präsident plant 100 millionen
arbeitsplätze zu schaffen um der
nächsten generation in asien den weg zu
bereiten
willkommen in jakarta der hauptstadt
indonesiens kann einem land mit 270
millionen einwohnern an der außengrenze
von asian
die wirtschaftsleistung macht ein
drittel des gesamten bundes aus bis 2050
könnte indonesien die viertgrößte
volkswirtschaft der welt werden
[Musik]
indonesien hatte von beginn an eine
führungsrolle in asien
ist das größte land muss es eine quasi
neutrale rolle einnehmen damit die
nachbarn sich nicht bedroht fühlen
[Musik]
in den kommenden fünf bis zehn jahren
muss indonesien aber wohl eine stärkere
führungsrolle in asien nehmen
damit sie an stark werden und sich als
globales zentrum behaupten kann
präsident sarkozy hat das ehrgeizige
ziel die finanzielle inklusion
auszuweiten
es gibt ein programm für die vermittlung
finanzieller mündigkeit
gleichzeitig wenn das digitale bankwesen
und die relevanten teile des
finanzwesens mit hilfe der digitalen
marktwirtschaft ausgebaut
schreitet schnell voran und technologie
wird wo die lösung für inklusion und
mündigkeit sein
inklusion bildung und kompetenz werden
die entscheidenden bausteine
vernetzung war hier schon immer
schwierig doch die digitalisierung
schreitet den indonesien mit am
schnellsten voran
digitale technologie und digitale
telekommunikation finden immer mehr
verwendung
das können wir nutzen um den wohlstand
und die wirtschaft noch weiter
auszubauen und zu verstärken
darum beschleunigen wir die entwicklung
von zahlungssystemen find ick und
onlinehandel um die finanzielle
inklusion zu fördern
wir sehen darin auch eine großartige
chance für viele kleinunternehmen und
menschen ohne bankkonto
wer indonesien verstehen will muss die
abgeschiedenheit begreifen die
ausdehnung des archipels entspricht der
strecke von new york nach alaska das
land will in den kommenden fünf jahren
350 milliarden dollar in straßen brücken
und kraftwerke investieren um zumindest
einen teil der 17.000 inseln zu
verbinden
präsident djukow widodo hat bereits
beachtliche fortschritte erzielt
in seiner ersten amtszeit wurden mit
ähnlich hohen investitionen straßen im
ganzen land erbaut
das nahverkehrssystem in jakarta gilt
als symbol für dieses vorhaben
die hauptstadt hat nun auch einen neuen
flughafen und günstige airlines die die
großen städte miteinander verbinden die
einzige billionenschwere volkswirtschaft
von asien wächst jedes jahr um etwa fünf
prozent
es geht nicht nur um physische
verbindung sondern auch um die vielen
probleme bei datenströmen zahlungen
besteuerung und auch datenschutz und
sicherheit
und um fachkräfte
für die vierte freiheit die
bewegungsfreiheit der arbeiter erreichen
und uns auf die digitalisierung
konzentrieren könnten würde das die
arbeiter ströme in ganz asien verbessern
wenn wir den markt digital und im
hinblick auf datenströme vereinen würden
könnten wir china konkurrenz machen
wir haben so viele reformen erforderlich
damit die asien starten das finanzwesen
tiefgreifend um und ausbauen könnten
und dann ein instrument auf basis ihrer
währungen zu erschaffen
würden externe regionale faktoren in den
hintergrund treten
könnte seine wirtschaftsentwicklung
selbst in die hand nehme
die finanzielle inklusion ist ein
hauptaugenmerk in der region die
finanzielle möglichkeit ist hingegen
eher niedrig ist das eine große
herausforderung wie wollen sie alle ins
boot holen
tunesien muss im bereich finanzieller
inklusion noch aufholen ebenso wie
indien
wir sind zwei große volkswirtschaften
wenn wir dabei fortschritte erzählen
wird das globale auswirkungen haben
das asian eine rolle für die
weltwirtschaft spielen wird es
unausweichlich
unsere wirtschaft ist schon jetzt
jährlich 3 billionen dollar schwer
mit einem wachstum von fünf prozent im
jahr sind wir in 14 jahren bei 6 bis 7
die ganze weltwirtschaft beträgt etwa
100 millionen dollar wir sind schon
jetzt ein nennenswerter teil der
weltwirtschaft
in den nächsten 14 bis 18 jahren werden
wir noch weiter wachsen
größe bedeutet auch einfluss
doch asien wird oft vorgeworfen dass die
veränderung kraftlos sein weil sie auf
sanften konsens setzen mit dem man keine
veränderungen bewirken könne
in anbetracht der wachsenden
verunsicherung auf der welt muss asien
stärker auftreten sich in ostasien
etablieren und der unsicherheit mit
multilateralismus begegnen
wir müssen uns als mittelmacht
positionieren
und die usa sind die großen
ob sie sie streiten oder freundlich
miteinander umgehen für uns gibt es
probleme und
asien als mittelmacht etablieren
was ist ihre vision für asian in zehn
jahren
wir sind im aufschwung global betrachtet
sind wir die einzige region die
wirtschaftlich durchgehend gut dasteht
das ist eine folge unserer pragmatischen
politik und davon dass wir hier gesunde
konkurrenz fördern
in dieser region gilt ein wachstum von
immerhin fünf prozent als schwache
leistung
es gibt ein berühmtes ich glaube
afrikanisches sprichwort
willst die schnell sein die allein
wollt ihr weit kommen geht zusammen
er spricht durchaus einiges für
umfassenden konsens doch die wahre
schönheit von asian liegt in der
flexibilität
die einzelnen länder und regionen haben
politisch viel spielraum das zu tun was
sie für richtig erachten ohne gängelung
durch eine asian weite politik
der präsident indonesiens versprach 100
millionen neue arbeitsplätze in den
arbeitsmarkt für die vierte industrielle
revolution neu zu starten hier ist asia
next generation
wer asien bereits sie viele junge
menschen denn das durchschnittliche
alter liegt bei nur 29 jahren
ein beachtlicher abstand zur politischen
führung im alter von 70 jahren
was an asian begeistert sie in bezug auf
die nächsten zehn jahre am meisten
ich denke es ist die nächste generation
junger anführer in politik und
wirtschaft insbesondere beim
online-handel
es gibt eine generation junger
führungspersonen sowohl in der politik
und in der wirtschaft als auch in der
kunst im medien und entertainment
bereich in mode kultur und
zivilgesellschaft
die nur auf ihren einsatz wartet
wir werden in ganz asien in acht bis
zwölf jahren sehen was sie bewirken
können acht bis zwölf jahre sind schnell
vorbei
wie genau werden die neuen anführer
asian formen
den acht bis zwölf jahren wird es eine
stärkere südostasiatische identität
geben nicht mehr so sehr eine thai oder
filipino identität es deutet viel auf
eine südostasiatische eine asian
identität hin
die junge generation hat zwar eine
andere wahrnehmung von asian als mir
aber auch für sie gehört asien bereits
dazu
man identifiziert sich mit seiner region
und jugend ist nun mal die zukunft der
region
wir haben unsere nationale identität
sind aber auch ein teil der region
südostasien
reisen die vernetzung günstige
flugtickets ausland visa und digitaler
informationsaustausch verbinden uns
durch die digitale vernetzung wissen
junge menschen viel mehr überein
präsident sarkozy plant nach eigener
aussage in fünf jahren 100 millionen
arbeitsplätze zu schaffen
trotz des schnellen wachstums der
größten volkswirtschaft in asien fällt
es vielen jungen leuten schwer arbeit zu
finden daher verschiebt sich der fokus
weg von den althergebrachten gewerben
hin zur bildung für die vierte
industrielle revolution
mit digitaler technologie kann jeder ein
unternehmer werden
mit plattformen wie beispielsweise
ballack in indonesien kann das sogar im
grundschüler
sie verdienen über das internet geld mit
ihrem hobby weil sie mal am markt sind
die nachfrage besteht
technologie bietet kleinunternehmern in
indonesien asien und auf der ganzen welt
große chancen
sie haben einen effizienteren
effektiveren zugang zum markt
das problem ist unser verständnis dieses
digitalen ökosystems damit wir allen
eine faire chance geben können
die technologie und die digitale
ökonomie zu verstehen ist die
schwierigste politische diskussion
unserer zeit um jobs teilhabe und
chancen die zu generieren
in indonesien gibt es bereits einige
programme zur förderung finanzieller
inklusion
das sozialprogramm der regierung wird
bereits digitalisiert
unser ziel für das letzte jahr waren 15
millionen familien dieses jahr sind es
24 millionen alles digital
auch der staatliche personenverkehr wird
digitalisiert
dadurch kommt der bevölkerungsteil ohne
bankkonten zum vorschein wodurch für in
indonesien die finanzielle inklusion von
40 prozent auf 60 prozent und demnächst
hoffentlich auf 70 erhöhen können
[Musik]
bewegungen auf dem arbeitsmarkt ist
immer ein heikles thema wie gehen wir
mit ungelernten arbeitskräften um wie
mit facharbeiter
ungelernte arbeitskräfte werden
weiterhin ein brisantes thema bleiben an
dem wir aber schon bilateral arbeit
wir sollten uns aber auch mit
fachkräften und der ausbildung befassen
für den nächsten entwicklungsschritt
unserer jeweiligen nationen un für die
zukunft der wirtschaftlichen integration
wird es unerlässlich sein dass wir uns
zeitnah mit diesen baustein für die
wirtschaftliche integration befassen
finanzielle inklusion und vernetzung
sind die großen themen indonesien mit
gutem grund plant hier war der oecd
zufolge sind kleinunternehmer für 97
prozent der arbeitsplätze und 56 prozent
aller investitionen verantwortlich
sie zu unterstützen und zu fördern
stärkt die wirtschaft
über 60 prozent aller erwachsenen in
indonesien haben mobiltelefone
kleinunternehmer mögen die digitale
wirtschaft die industrie 4.0 dann so
können sie einfach und kostengünstig am
markt teilhaben
kojak und kopie beispielsweise
verletzten zunächst 500.000 indonesia
mittlerweile über eine million
jetzt expandieren sie in alle großen
städte indonesiens
derartige angebote und kleinunternehmen
im allgemeinen die früher durch
ungleichen zugang zu informationen vom
markt ausgeschlossen waren sind jetzt
große akteure und genießen die vorzüge
früher lag unser hauptaugenmerk darauf
kleinunternehmen
indem wir ihnen mehr unternehmerische
chancen ermöglichten
indonesien tut vieles um
kleinunternehmer zu unterstützen
die digitale wirtschaft das digitale
finanzwesen und start-ups beschleunigen
nun die entwicklung von kleinunternehmen
in indonesien reden wir gern vom
kleinunternehmen dass sein eigenes
produkt früher auf der straße verkaufte
und jetzt dank dem online handel bereits
im export tätig ist
die technologische revolution ist die
zukunft wir nennen es die fünfte
freiheit
die etablierten vier freiheiten in asien
sind freie verkehr von waren
dienstleistungen
investitionen und menschen die fünfte
ist der datenverkehr
wenn die wirtschaftliche integration in
asien gelingen soll müssen wir uns mit
dem datenverkehr befassen
asien ist insofern unsere übungsgelände
auf dem wir uns zunächst zur übung unter
nachbarn miteinander vernetzen bevor wir
uns global öffnen
das ist eine wichtige perspektive
besonders bedeutsam für asien sind
indonesiens einhörner
ich denke checa viel wachstumspotenzial
unser ziel markt ist schließlich die
gesamte mittelschicht südostasien
und jetzt milliardenschwere firmen
verbinden die nächste generation in
asien
indonesien ist das land der einhörner
show coupe dia treffer locker und kojak
sind drei firmen die das land zum herz
der internetwirtschaft machten
durch das internet und mobiltelefone
bekommen millionen kleinunternehmen und
hunderte millionen menschen zugang zu
märkten und dem finanzwesen
in indonesien gibt es mehr als 75
millionen krafträder
sie in jakarta per rad sharing zu
vermieten schien also eine gute idee zu
sein so gut dass kojak jetzt einen
marktwert von über 10 milliarden dollar
erreichte gold jack hat großen einfluss
in asien denn sie bieten auch logistik
lebensmittel und fynn tags und
expandieren immer weiter
wir hatten nach nur zwei drei monaten
einen anteil von 30 bis 35 prozent am
zweiradmarkt in vietnam
wir waren überrascht wie schnell sich
das entwickelt sicher auch ein erfolg
der app aber es geht auch darum neue
branchen zu erschließen und die
reichweite unserer dienste in indonesien
unserem größten markt zu erhöhen
man kann an unseren investoren zu denen
schwergewichte wie google tencent
ggsc temasek und auch motoren gehören
bereits erkennen dass wir in allen
wichtigen industriezweigen in denen wir
aktiv sind nach der weltspitze streben
um die erste globale super app für alle
täglichen bedürfnisse zu erstellen
technologie vereinfacht diese
integration zusätzlich
die wirtschafts einhörner und die
digitale wirtschaft in asien sind ein
faktor für die beschleunigung dieser
integration
oder travel logo sind alle regional
aktiv und werden der impulsgeber für die
weitere integration der wirtschaft in
ganz asien seien
die sättigung auf dem verbrauchermarkt
ist im vergleich zu china immer noch
verschwindend klein
unsere transport lebensmittel zahlungs
dienstleistungs logistik und digital
branchen können noch stark wachsen also
stehen wir immer noch am anfang
kojak hat also noch gewaltiges
wachstumspotenzial denn unsere
potentielle zielgruppe ist die gesamte
mittelschicht südostasiens
glücklicherweise hat präsident djukow
wie einen guten draht zu millennials und
der generations at der kommenden
generation
bei fernsehdebatten im wahlkampf brachte
er themen wie sports und videospiel
turniere zur sprache ebenso wie den
online handel die digitale wirtschaft
und wirtschafts ein herner
ich bin zuversichtlich dass die ziele
und wünsche dem landes und der
generations im rahmen der kommenden vier
um in asien deutlich stärker zum tragen
kommen werden
china ist seit zehn jahren der größte
handelspartner von asian
einen handelskurs zwischen peking und
washington zu finden ist angesichts der
spannungen nur eine von vielen
außenpolitischen herausforderungen
die probleme im südchinesischen meer
spalten und
das trans pazifischen handelsabkommen
spaltet uns und doch besteht asien fort
und macht weiter fortschritte
wenn auch in manchen jahren etwas
langsamer
insgesamt sind wir jedoch immer gewählt
uns der nächsten herausforderung zu
stellen
buchstäblich ein drehkreuz des
welthandels
90 prozent des handels aus dem nahen in
den fernen osten läuft über indonesien
durch die straße von malakka
dadurch sind wir sehr offen für den
internationalen handel sowie in gewisser
weise für investitions tourismus und
haben eine hohe toleranz für eine
vielzahl anderen kulturen aus aller welt
entwickelt
wenn wir zehn jahre in die zukunft
blicken müssen wir asien japan südkorea
und china gemeinsam betrachten
wie beeinflusste dynamik all dieser
ostasiatischen länder die beschleunigte
integration
die aktuelle riechen auf der intec wie
verlangsamt die integration
es ist schließlich reizvoll sich mit all
diesen ländern zu vernetzen und nicht
bevorzugt nur innerhalb von asien
für mich ist das glas halb voll
ich bin zuversichtlich dass asien sich
weiterhin behaupten kann und
dass die krise des globalen
handelssystems und des multilateralismus
für uns eine warnung oder nach
möglichkeit etwas positives eine chance
darstellen wird
dass wir wieder erstarken können und das
gleichgewicht in dieser zunehmend
polarisierten welt darstellen das in
kissing dem artikel mit einer starken
regionalen präsenz und einer festen
stimme und mitsprache angesichts der
multilateralen und regionalen
verunsicherung
was wird sich in asien am meisten
verändern
es wird anders als alles bisher
dagewesene sein
denn es überschneidet sich mit dem
aufkommen von industrie 4.0 cloud
computing und künstliche intelligenz der
ganzen zukunftstechnologie
die bevölkerung sieht ost asiens von
asian hat sich als unglaublich offen
vier neue technologie erwiesen für
soziale medien
mehr als wohl überall sonst auf der welt
diese fächer verbringen bis zu drei
monate auf see und mit einem empfang im
wert von 70.000 dollar zurück zu kehren
solche traditionsunternehmen waren die
lebensader indonesiens doch der
generationen war läutet eine neue
zukunft ein
die strahlende silhouette von singapur
der finanz drehscheibe von asian und
eine der teuersten städte der welt
in singapur treffen privates
unternehmertum und geld aufeinander ein
großteil der erfolgsgeschichte asiens
geht auf privates unternehmertum zurück
asien wächst bei nacht wenn die
regierung schläft bis zu 60 prozent
aller projekte in asien werden über die
banken singapurs finanziert
die privatwirtschaft hat ihre wünsche
der stadt hingegen ist für sein volk
verantwortlich und muss ihr vermitteln
damit alles zusammenpasst wenn
wir privatwirtschaft und öffentlicher
hand bündeln können wir die nötigen
mittel für diese projekte aufbringen
die finanzierung der infrastruktur ist
eine der herausforderungen für die
nächste generation in asien
ich bin haslinger armen willkommen in
singapur der stadtstaat macht mit knapp
sechs millionen einwohnern weniger als
ein prozent der bevölkerung von asian
aber fast zwölf prozent der
wirtschaftsleistung aus singapur ist das
zentrum für finanzen und infrastruktur
südost asiens
etwas wie singapur gibt es irgendwo
sonst in der region
die kleine insel ist über den größten
flughafen der region und in zweit
größten containerhafen der welt mit dem
rest der welt verbunden
die stadt bietet hochentwickelte
finanzmärkte bildung und fachkompetenz
in asien gibt es sowohl kleine länder
die in der entwicklung hinterherhinken
als auch auf der anderen seite
hochmoderne industrienationen wie
singapur die am völlig anderen ende des
spektrums stehen
also einen homogenen markt mit homogenem
kaufverhalten und gleiche chancen
anzunehmen spiegelt offensichtlich nicht
die realität wider
investoren aus aller welt sagen zur
investition in den asien immer wieder
ihre entscheidung viele für in china
anders aus als für thailand oder
singapur
daran scheitert es in der realität
leider oft
die bse ist die grösste bank
südostasiens die hälfte ihrer geschäfte
entfällt auf singapur und die hälfte
ihres umsatzes stammt aus institutional
banking ein großteil der
erfolgsgeschichte asiens geht auf
privates unternehmertum zurück
asien wächst bei nacht wenn die
regierung schläft für mich ist die
privatwirtschaft die treibende kraft der
integration
die firmen streben danach
grenzübergreifend zusammenzuarbeiten und
die verbraucher wären ihrerseits mit den
füßen wehren
die privatwirtschaft und einzelpersonen
treiben die geschichte voran und nehmen
dabei die regierung und den staatlichen
sektor
die meisten regierungen wollen das
gleiche ihr volk glücklich machen wofür
sie infrastruktur brauchen
verschiedene länder verfolgen hierbei
verschiedene ansätze
manche verlassen sich stark auf die
privatwirtschaft andere setzen auf
staatliche betriebe
ich bin ein verfechter öffentlich
privater partnerschaften
wie engagieren uns auf diese art auf den
philippinen und ich glaube dass der
private sektor insbesondere in
anbetracht seines wachsenden budgets in
der pflicht steht sich gewissenhaft und
mit gebotenem ernst an bisher
üblicherweise staatlichen projekten zu
beteiligen
man muss es aus der perspektive der
privatwirtschaft ziehen sie werden nur
handeln wenn die projekte eine
angemessene rendite versprechen
hat man das geschafft muss man dafür
sorgen dass alles gut strukturiert ist
wobei auch der regulatorische rahmen der
investitionen von bedeutung ist
die asiatische entwicklungsbank rechnet
für die infrastruktur bedürfnisse in
asien mit erforderlichen ausgaben von
3,1 billionen dollar in zehn jahren
singapur hat mit infrastructure eine
zentrale anlaufstelle eingerichtet
[Musik]
der ausbau der kompetenzen der länder
ist auch von bedeutung
denn die beamten oder anderweitige
verantwortliche eines landes müssen
imstande sein ein vorgeschlagenes
strukturiertes projekt einschätzen zu
können
man will hier nicht nur ein projekt
umsetzen sondern seinem volk einen
mehrwert bieten so arbeitsplätze den
austausch von fachwissen und natürlich
die direkten vorteile des projekts
die beiden bereiche müssen
zusammenarbeiten
denn der staatssektor muss sich
schließlich sowohl bei den richtlinien
als auch bei der infrastruktur mit der
privatwirtschaft koordinieren die
öffentliche hand muss also an der
entwicklung von zahlungs mechanismen
ebenso wie an der harmonisierung von
kapitalmärkten beteiligt sein
ohne zusammenarbeit geht es nicht auch
wenn die privatwirtschaft oft
federführend sein wird
singapur ist für viele ein vorbild
nicht nur in asien sondern auf der
ganzen welt
insbesondere im hinblick darauf dass die
öffentliche hand sehr darauf bedacht ist
sich bestmöglich auf trends in der
privatwirtschaft und weltweit
beobachtete entwicklungen einzustellen
[Musik]
ist eine der größten konzerne thailand
das infrastrukturunternehmen ist seit
über 100 jahren in der region von asian
aktiv
die glasfront des hauptsitzes erlaubt
einen blick auf den hauptbahnhof von
bangkok der bald schnellzug linien von
singapur bis nach china verbinden wird
thailand investiert stark in
infrastruktur ebenso wie es auch länder
wie vietnam und indonesien
wir beobachten auch den trend die
infrastrukturen der länder von asien mit
china zu vernetzen
wir gehen also davon aus dass der
schwerpunkt zumindest staatlicher
investitionen in den kommenden zehn
jahren auf der infrastruktur liegen wird
die länder wollen für die aufstrebende
mittelschicht städte bauen große wie
kleine
sie müssen also viele städte planen und
aber alles mögliche bedenken
abfallmanagement hygiene
wasserversorgung elektrizität und
kommunikation sind einige der
wiederkehrenden kernpunkte in den
ländern rund um singapur
wenn wir privatwirtschaft und
öffentlicher hand bündeln können wir die
nötigen mittel für diese projekte
aufbringen
die meisten länder in asien hätten bei
der infrastruktur entwicklung hinterher
was auch am logans werten starken
wachstum liegt doch die massive
verstädterung wie wir sie in den
großstädten manila jakarta und bangkok
beobachten können offenbart uns wie groß
der bedarf an zukunftsfähige
infrastruktur tatsächlich ist
jedes land braucht einen
maßgeschneiderten ansatz im
hochentwickelten singapur haben wir es
mit ganz anderen herausforderungen zu
tun als beispielsweise in myanmar laos
oder kambodscha
darum passen wir unsere herangehensweise
für die jeweiligen länder und ihre
bedürfnisse an damit wir die richtigen
lösungen anbieten können
vor 130 jahren installierte general
electric auf den philippinen die erste
glühbirne
als nächstes sehen wir uns die
energieversorgung für die zukunft von
asian an
65 millionen menschen ein zehntel der
bevölkerung lebt ohne elektrizität in
manchen ländern hat nicht mal ein
drittel strom
[Musik]
asian ist im wandel nicht nur bei der
vernetzung und inklusion sondern auch in
sachen nachhaltigkeit
kohle ist hier der hauptlieferant für
strom doch der bedarf ist in den letzten
15 jahren um 60 prozent gestiegen
[Musik]
65 millionen menschen ein zehntel der
bevölkerung lebt ohne elektrizität
in manchen ländern hat nicht mal ein
drittel strom in singapur wiederum 100
prozent die energiegewinnung muss daher
unbedingt ausgebaut werden
wir fokussieren uns auf diesen bereich
und bieten glücklicherweise ein
vollständiges portfolio an erneuerbaren
lösungen wind sonne energie speicher
aber auch thermische technologien wie
gas und kohle
jedes land hat seine eigene situation
und eigene ressourcen manche haben keine
ressourcen und müssen importieren darum
brauchen sie alle individuelle lösungen
damit die länder der region ihr
potenzial entfalten können brauchen sie
energieversorgung was sind hierbei die
herausforderungen
das problem ist dass die
energieversorgung in der vergangenheit
über herkömmliche fossile energieträger
folgt jetzt aber wurde klimaschutz und
nachhaltigkeit ein großes thema mit
gutem grund
den energiebedarf und das verlangen nach
nachhaltigkeit ins gleichgewicht zu
bringen ist die herausforderung
glücklicherweise haben sich
preisunterschiede und kosteneffizienz
erneuerbarer energien in den letzten
fünf jahren stark verbessert
somit sehen wir eine chance den anteil
erneuerbarer energien deutlich zu
erhöhen
energy corp
die adia jana group ist eines der
ältesten und größten konglomerate der
philippinen die energie-sparte arbeitet
an milliardenschweren projekten für
erneuerbare energiequellen auf den
philippinen in indonesien und in vietnam
hat sich das ziel gesetzt bis 2025 23
prozent seines stroms aus erneuerbaren
quellen zu beziehen die meisten
regierungen haben mittlerweile ein viel
stärkeres bewusstsein dafür und streben
nach erneuerbarer energie wir müssen
unser portfolio entsprechend anpassen
und sonst hier stärker einbringen die
deckung des energiebedarfs auf
nachhaltige weise ist die große
herausforderung sowohl für die
privatwirtschaft als auch für die
öffentliche hand
das ziel der nachhaltigkeit musste man
schon immer als gleichgewicht betrachten
der klimawandel ist ein großes problem
wohl das größte problem der nächsten 10
15 jahre aber auch hier gibt es nicht
die radikale antwort wäre sämtliche
nutzung fossiler energieträger
einzustellen südostasien wird aber in
den kommenden zehn fünfzehn jahren
gewaltigen energiebedarf haben weshalb
es heute keine echte alternative dazu
gibt
banken wie die ubs und die wollen nur
noch grüne nachhaltige projekte
unterstützen
das in einer region die nach günstige
energie verlangt realistisch von kohle
noch die vorherrschende energiequelle
ist
ich denke die welt und auch die banken
tun hier das richtige und verlagern den
fokus hin zur nachhaltigkeit
wir haben unsererseits das langfristige
ziel dass die hälfte der
energieproduktion unseres portfolios aus
nachhaltigen quellen stammen zahlen es
geht immer um ein gleichgewicht ich sehe
mich nicht als radikal
es sollte in richtung erneuerbarer
energiequellen gehen aber es gibt
anwendungsfälle bei denen fossile
energieträger noch immer die
effizienteste lösung
wir müssen zwar den energiebedarf
unserer zeit decken können aber nicht
ewig so weitermachen da die zukunft
sonst düster aussieht
brauchen wir die balance und müssen dann
den anteil thermische energie verringern
wobei auch banken eine wichtige rolle
spielen
wir müssen den menschen alternativen
also finanzieren wir verstärkt
erneuerbare projekte solarstrom
windenergie und auch die masse
der us-gigant general electric sieht in
südostasien ein gewaltiges
wachstumspotential der umsatz des
unternehmens in der region hat sich in
acht jahren auf sieben milliarden dollar
verdoppelt das unternehmen hat in der
region 10.000 beschäftigte
die größte wachstumschance liegt in
enger zusammenarbeit der länder
miteinander in laos wird im norden viel
energie für den export nach vietnam und
thailand produziert während im süden
viel energie aus vietnam und thailand
importiert wird
das stromnetz ist also der schlüssel
dazu die energie am richtigen ort nutzen
zu können
in bezug auf die physische infrastruktur
und die vernetzung der länder
untereinander hat die region noch luft
nach oben
inklusives wachstum und inklusive
entwicklung stehen im fokus wie können
sie ländern wie indonesien einem
riesigen archiv mit 17.000 inseln helfen
die lücke zu schließen
indonesien ist ein interessantes
beispiel
hier sind sowohl große kraftwerke
erforderlich wie er auf java oder
sumatra in dicht besiedelten gebieten
als auch kleinere systeme auf fossiler
basis für die entlegenen regionen
wir haben erst kürzlich viele entlegene
inseln elektrifiziert mit größtenteils
autonomen
lösungen
für die regierung war es ein großer
erfolg energie in regionen zu bringen
die vorher keine stromversorgung hatten
fast alle länder haben
infrastrukturpläne in höhe von hunderten
milliarden dollar und dennoch fehlt es
in südostasien markant an infrastruktur
was wäre die wichtigste maßnahme dagegen
das wachstum war so gewaltig dass wir
erst wieder aufholen müssen
die infrastruktur können wir das
wachstum aber auf lange sicht
aufrechterhalten ich bin der ansicht
dass wir insbesondere in
wirtschaftlichen schwerpunkten die
infrastruktur vorausschauend und mit
ausreichend reserven ausbauen sollten um
das wachstum aufrechterhalten
regierungen müssen hierbei aber auch
politische und gesellschaftliche
probleme bedenken weshalb nicht immer
alles perfekt laufen kann
als nächstes betrachten wir wie vietnam
den wandel begrüßt von hanoi und ho chi
minh
[Musik]
der größte nutzen von fynn tags sind
verringert die kosten für so gut wie
alles technologie ist grundsätzlich
deflationär die kosten für zugang und
transaktionen sinken kunden können
bessere angebote bekommen
wenn die kosten also sinken können auch
weniger weit entwickelte länder eine
bessere abdeckung ihrer finanzsysteme
erreichen
ich sehe hier keine nachteile
unsere länder arbeiten daran
geschäftstätigkeiten zu erleichtern
und ebenso über gesetze und richtlinien
firmen die richtigen anreize zu geben in
diesen ländern zu investieren
es ist nicht einfach über landesgrenzen
und vor allem steuer und rechts bereiche
hinweg tätig zu sein
[Musik]
das ist meiner meinung nach unsere
aktuell größte herausforderung
die großen städte in asien werden sich
stark modernisieren und smart cities
werden sie werden sich an die
anforderungen der zukunft anpassen
nachhaltiger und umweltfreundlicher
werden mit weniger stau auf der straße
es gibt bis dahin noch viel zu tun aber
die art wie städte funktionieren und mit
energie versorgt werden wird sich in den
nächsten jahren drastisch ändern
wenn es bei öffentlich privaten
partnerschaften um wirklich
gesellschaftlich nützliche themen wie
öffentlichen nahverkehr geht
grundlegende infrastruktur für die
verbindung von menschen und wirtschaft
wird daraus eine inklusive komponente
die menschen in allen bereichen betrifft
insbesondere in den unteren
gesellschaftsschichten in
großen städten sind nahverkehrsprojekte
besonders wichtig da es in südostasien
sonst sehr schwierig ist sich in der
stadt zu bewegen major cities
[Musik]
das erwartete wirtschaftswachstum
philippinen wurde für 2009 10 mit fast 7
von den fünf größten volkswirtschaften
von asian am höchsten eingeschätzt
vietnam gehört nicht zu ihnen ist aber
auf einem ähnlichen kurs
ich befasse mich jetzt schon seit über
20 jahren mit vietnam und könnte den
wandel weg von strikter staatlicher
kontrolle hin zu einer flexibleren
marktwirtschaft mit privatkapital
deutlich beobachten
die richtung scheint klar aber sie haben
noch einen weiten weg vor sich
verglichen mit den marktorientierten
asien starten ist es in vietnam immer
noch deutlich schwerer etwas auf die
beine zu stellen
sie intensivieren ihr investment in
erneuerbare energien in vietnam warum
sie boten investoren für kurze zeit
reizvolle zelle und gebühren wenn man
überlegt wo man investieren will und
eine regierung plötzlich anreize schafft
zieht das natürlich kapital an
vietnam war sehr offen für spezifische
nachhaltige projekte
wir hatten das know-how ein geeignetes
team und die finanziellen mittel das
projekt durchzuführen
also sagten wir zu
sein ist eine interessante region und
wird man war bezüglich der investitions
angebote sehr großzügig also ergriffen
wir die chance und macht nun ans werk zu
großen projekten fällt mir als erstes
unsere beteiligung am petrochemie
komplexen zitierten am 1 nike minh stadt
da ging es um knapp 5,4 milliarden us
dollar
der bau hat bereits begonnen ein zehntel
ist schon geschafft
wir rechnen damit dass es in dreieinhalb
oder vier jahren kommerziell in betrieb
gehen kann
es ist der erste petrochemische komplex
in vietnam
das ist die größte herausforderung für
asia
fangen wir zuerst mit etwas positivem an
bevor wir von den problemen reden
die region macht sich sehr gut das
gesamtwachstum in südostasien ganz asien
ist ein strahlendes vorbild und wird das
auch noch eine weile bleiben
die herausforderung besteht darin das
wachstum nachhaltig planbar und
langfristig haltbar zu machen
wir sehen faszinierende entwicklungen
wie gewaltige urbanisierung was
natürlich eine infrastruktur
herausforderung darstellt das lässt sich
in allen großen städten südost asiens
beobachten
es gibt mittlerweile etwa 1800 flugzeuge
in asien in den nächsten zehn jahren
werden nochmal 2200 dazu kommen es wird
sich also mehr als verdoppeln ebenso die
energieversorgung heute haben wir eine
leistung von 260 gigawatt und in den
nächsten zehn jahren kommen noch mal 200
gigawatt dazu das gleiche im
gesundheitswesen das wächst auch seit
jahren stetig um etwa zehn prozent in
der region sind tausende neue
krankenhäuser geplant
auch die vernetzung der menschen wird
besser
das liegt zum teil an technologien die
es uns erlauben kulturelle und
sprachliche barrieren einfacher zu
überwinden
für mich persönlich ist das
die bedeutendste verbesserung die ich
zwischen den ländern von asian in den
letzten vier oder fünf jahren beobachten
konnte
ein großer unterschied es die
verbreitung von marken aus asien
gerade im technologiesektor treten
marken aus asien immer stärker in den
vordergrund
anders als früher das hat sich geändert
die angriffe änderung ist der wunsch und
das behutsame streben nach markt
integration
staatspolitik und privates
unternehmertum innerhalb und über
grenzen hinweg partnerschaften und
geteilter wohlstand im namen des volkes
sie sind die zukunft von asian
technologie auf ihn und mobil sind sie
eine völlig neue art verbraucher
noch vision und fertig schnell einfach
intuitiv wurde mehr als ein drittel der
640 millionen menschen von asian sind
zwischen 15 und 34 wir sind eine der
beliebtesten marken bei jugendlichen um
gelerntes perfekt für eine der jüngsten
bevölkerungen der welt der wandel
erschossen
wir sind passieren schafft kann es
überall schaffen
freizeit lifestyle online-handel und
führung heute sind alle voller
leidenschaft und zuversicht mit know-how
aus aller welt
sie sind die nächste generation in asia
willkommen in bangkok der hauptstadt
thailands der zweitgrößten
volkswirtschaft von asia bibi ganz
südostasien den höhenflug der online
wirtschaft nutzen will
die ganze regierung setzt dabei auf eine
neue jüngere verbraucher schicht
das durchschnittsalter liegt bei nur 29
jahren somit sind millennial sg
treibende kraft einer florierenden
mittelschicht der bis 2030 330 millionen
menschen angehören könnten mehr als das
doppelte verglichen mit 2009 10
in den letzten 30 jahren hat sich so
viel verändert
als sie hierher kommt und zwar aus aber
kein wort sprach zügig allerlei komische
blicke an
heute sind alle voller leidenschaft und
zuversicht mit know-how aus aller welt
die so gedanken meeresschildkröten
kommen zurück sie waren im ausland
bringen das wissen und die leidenschaft
aus aller welt zurück in ihre heimat
technologie wird aktuelle entwicklungen
nur beschleunigen
besser und günstiger
indonesien und ganz asien gibt es viele
junge und hart arbeitende menschen die
sehr vernetzt sind und probleme lösen
wollen
technologie wird ganz asien nur helfen
asien zu etwas bringen kann schafft es
überall
umgekehrt nicht unbedingt
plötzlich müssen wir nicht mehr wie
früher traditionelle logistik und
telekommunikationsnetze aufbauen 5g
breitet sich zum beispiel sehr schnell
in der region aus
der digitale konsum ist gewaltig ohne
wie bisher üblich lange voll auf phasen
die nächsten zwei oder drei jahre werden
in südostasien die kritische phase sein
das wachstum in den kommenden 15 jahren
wird gewaltig sowohl in bezug auf konsum
als auch investitionen und die
entwicklung der ganzen region
zurück die sich im ausland ausbilden
ließen und andere länder kennen landen
täglich steigt das bildungsniveau der
arbeiterschaft in nie dagewesenem maße
unsere generation ist besser ausgebildet
und viel reicher als alle
klaus vater war der malaysische
immobilien und investment
mit zwei freunden mit ähnlichem
hintergrund wollte sie den größten
unabhängigen investmentfonds südost
asiens erschaffen
investmentfonds
südostasien ist für uns der
interessanteste markt und würde es wegen
der jungen bevölkerung auch noch zehn 15
jahre lang bleiben
die generationen wandel verändert die
politik der konsum ist gewaltig und es
gibt eine hochgebildete sehr mobile
population die zum teil auch von außen
nach südostasien einreist
wir sollten nicht außer acht lassen dass
es nicht nur um diejenigen geht die
bereits da sind sondern dass viele sogar
hierher kommen wollen
somit werden viele innovative ideen in
diesem teil der welt gelangen
asien hat in den letzten 60 jahren
gewaltige fortschritte gemacht handel
und wirtschaftsleistung sind um das 20
bis 30 fache gestiegen
technologie kann diese entwicklung noch
weiter beschleunigen denn sie macht
nicht nur die produktion schneller
besser und günstiger
sondern löst auch probleme schneller
in indonesien und ganz asien den können
viele probleme bei der infrastruktur im
zahlungsverkehr in bezug auf
arbeitskräfte und know how durch
technologie gelöst werden
es ist für uns in südostasien
unglaublich wichtig in talente zu
investieren wir haben gerade erst unsere
zentrale in singapur eingeweiht eine
finte zentrale immer leise eingerichtet
und bilden dadurch von beginn an
hunderte menschen aus
zusätzlich bringen wir experten aus
silicon valley und europa hier her um
den austausch zu fördern
mittelfristig wollen wir talente in der
gesamten region fördern
1 million ist ein unternehmer aus asien
im höhenflug und wurde durch die ipo
seiner firma razor milliardär
der gebürtige singapurer will seinem
unternehmen mit sitz in
südostasien zu einem neuen
wachstumsschub verhelfen wir sehen
südostasien als einen gewaltigen
wachstumsmarkt für uns wie unser
unternehmen
die sehr junge bevölkerung ist überaus
technologie affine und verlangt geradezu
nach konsum und entertainment
darin sehen wir bei razer eine gewaltige
chance sofern wir es schaffen passende
produkte für die bevölkerung der region
anzubieten
unsere digitale wirtschaft ist china
zehn jahre hinterher aber wir holen
schneller auf als alle vor uns china
die usa und europa brauchten viel länger
für den ausbau der digitalen wirtschaft
wir stehen noch am anfang aber bewegen
uns schon schneller als alle anderen
wirtschaftszonen zuvor hier einige
beispiele für die vernetzung südost
asiens die philippinen führen weltweit
bei der nutzung sozialer medien in asien
bei der handynutzung für den
online-handel und thailand beim internet
browsing über das handy
unsere internetnutzung ist hochgradig
mobil
wir sind viel unterwegs als die
generation vor uns
technologie meiner meinung nach
schneller anpassungsfähiger und
intuitiver werden
anstatt fünf schritten brauchen wir nur
noch zwei wir wissen um sind fertig
schnell einfach und intuitiv
ich bin 2011 als zweiter mitarbeiter von
labbadia in die tech branche
eingestiegen
damals hatten wir 20 prozent der
menschen in thailand internetzugang
heute sind es 70 oder 80 prozent
der handybesitzer liegt wohl bei 110
prozent spricht jeder hat mindestens ein
handy
gab es vor zehn jahren so einfach nicht
das musste sich erst entwickeln
heutzutage kann sogar mein mann aus
norwegen der in thailand lebt aber kein
wort teil spricht überall hinkommen
und ich rede nicht nur von taxis er kann
geschäfte machen mit anwälten reden
märkte erschließen es hat sich so viel
getan allein schon in bangkok
südostasiens online wirtschaft soll sich
durch die verbreitung des internets in
den nächsten fünf jahren mindestens
verdreifachen auf bis zu 250 milliarden
dollar
zwar verspricht die digitale wirtschaft
der jungen generation von asian
mannigfaltige chancen doch asien muss
den wandel noch vollziehen
sonst wird diese nächste generation zwar
alt aber nicht reich werden
das weltweite angebot im internet wächst
und der anteil vernetzter menschen ist
in manchen ländern sehr hoch während ein
großer teil von asien noch nicht mit
industrienationen mithalten kann wer in
indonesien das internet nutzen kann
macht regen gebrauch davon während über
30 prozent der bevölkerung noch gar
keinen zugang haben von gesundheit und
bildung ganz zu schweigen
droht indonesien allzu werden bevor der
reichtum kommt
das ist eine verbreitete ansicht wenn
wir nicht aufpassen könnte aus uns ein
land mit mittlerem einkommen wären somit
würden die vorhersagen indonesien könnte
in 20 oder 30 jahren platz fünf gesetzen
reine fantasie bleiben
genau daran will präsident djukow wie
arbeiten
wir müssen uns auf bedürfnisse
konzentrieren auf prozesses ebenso wie
die reiche infrastruktur
demographie ist der schlüssel zum erfolg
die demographie ist aber auch die
herausforderung wir müssen die richtige
bildung die richtigen einstellungen
vermitteln
[Musik]
ist ceo von
einer indonesischen investment firma die
in allen bereichen tätig ist vom bergbau
bis zur telekommunikation
damit die inklusion erfolg hat braucht
es gerechte bildung
wie soll das funktionieren
nach dem ausbau der hafeninfrastruktur
brücken helfen und straßen steht der
ausbau der reichen infrastrukturen
gesundheit und bildung
doch welche bildung ist am besten für
die industrialisierung 4.0 geeignet
wir müssen ja nicht nur gute schüler
ausbilden sondern brauchen auch ebenso
gute lehrerbildung
ich hatte gerade ein meeting zum thema
bildung für die massen
die millennials hier sind von dem thema
geradezu besessen
es geht nicht nur um work life balance
sondern um arbeit leben spiel und lernen
das lernen findet nicht länger von oben
herab stadt sondern auch anders herum
viele junge menschen sehnen sich nach
orten an denen sie etwas lernen aber
gleichzeitig auch spielen können
ich war heute erst bei drei bildung
startups sie warten nicht auf die
reformen des thailändischen
bildungsministeriums
indonesien den philippinen es ist quasi
das gleiche in ganz südostasien
sie gehen das ganze fernab alle
regulierungen rein pragmatisch
was braucht man wirklich um zu überleben
einen universitätsabschluss nicht jeder
wird dann mark zuckerberg solche genies
und selten
aber man kann fähigkeiten erlernen um
damit sein geld zu verdienen
schwimmen war 2012 mitbegründerin eine
online handelsplattform für frauen jetzt
gerät sie die investmentfirma gobi
partners zu tech startups in südostasien
ich werde ständig nach dem nächsten
einhorn gefragt
dass thailand ist aber für den aufbau
einer firma hier überhaupt nicht
geeignet
deshalb ist uns alle nach sich zieht
dort winken investitionen von firmen und
initiativen
davon gibt es in thailand zu wenig
das erste teil einhorn wird also auch
eine firma mit sitz in singapur sein
wenn man heute von startups redet geht
es oft um das silicon valley oder
shenzhen in china
wird sich südostasien irgendwann auch zu
etablieren können
es geschieht bereits bei uns entstehen
bereits technologie einhörner
aber nicht so sehr wie in china
das wird sich voraussichtlich in den
nächsten jahren deutlich ändern
in diesem teil der welt entstehen
vielmehr tech startups
selbst wir kommen aus dem silicon valley
zurück um nach interessanten firmen und
start ups zu suchen in die wir
investieren können
ich sehe hier in südostasien folglich
vor allem gewaltige chancen
das silicon valley bekommt aktuell
starke konkurrenz aus schengen kurzen
willst du dass da sie irgendwann auch
bei diesem rennen mitmischen
ich denke schon ich kenne ein paar leute
die ihre start-ups aus den usa nach
vietnam verlegen hier bekommen sie
fachkräfte für ein viertel der
arbeitskosten
kosten sind ein großer faktor und unser
markt hier ist sehr konkurrenzfähig mit
gut ausgebildeten fachkräften warum also
nicht
was steht dem weg
die politik wir müssen einen besseren
politischen umgang mit der
bewegungsfreiheit ausländische
arbeitskräfte finden
wirtschaft südost asiens ist noch nicht
gut genug integriert insbesondere im
vergleich mit europa sind wir wieder in
bezug auf fachkräfte mobilität noch bei
währungen konkurrenzfähig
unsere währungen fluktuieren stark und
willkürlich
die politik gibt die
entwicklungsbedingungen für ganz
südostasien vor
die ambitionen der jungen generationen
werden für die regierungen zunehmend
problematisch was sind die
herausforderungen
manche regierungen sehen sie als problem
andere als chance
die junge generation bezieht ihre
nachrichten und informationen nicht mehr
aus traditionellen quellen
sie gehen weniger ins kino lesen keine
zeitungen und sehen nicht fern manche
haben auch keinen fernseher was tun sie
denn sie spielen videospiele
sie nutzen gerne virtuelle währungen und
beziehen informationen aus sozialen
medien
viele regierungen erlernen den umgang
mit ihnen gerade neu in
welchen bereichen haben die millennials
wie viel beigetragen
eine interessante frage
ich habe mich des öfteren darüber
unterhalten wie die neue regierung von
malaysia ihre wirtschaft regelt
der meinung dass leere sache besser
machen als ihre vorgänger wobei mir die
meisten ökonomen widersprechen würden
kommt es ganz einfach wenn ich ein bier
tierwelt muss ich zwei stunden anstehen
im nagelstudio nicht sogar fünf stunden
warten
was die wirtschaftsleistung angeht
konnten wir im diesjährigen bericht
sehen dass der private verbrauch in
malaysia ganz malaysia über den
erwartungen lag
das lieblich an infrastruktur oder
öffentlichen einrichtungen
es ist die privatwirtschaft es gibt
einfach einen nischenmarkt der
vernachlässigt wurde die ausgaben der
millennials für verbrauchsgüter
opnext gleich sehen wir uns an wie die
nächste generation von asian eine
einmalige chance für die zukunft
ergreift
[Musik]
die integration von asien läuft so gut
wie es geht wir müssen realistisch
bleiben
die zehn länder sind wirtschaftlich
verschieden weit entwickelt es ist
schwierig sie als einheit mit
identischen riegeln und zellen zu
betrachten das geht einfach nicht
sie haben wird eine große region sein
das wachstum die stabilität die
demografische entwicklung all diese
faktoren tragen zum wachstum in der
region bei
die region ist auch wirtschaftlich
vielfältig
thailand hat seine stärken ebenso
malaysia singapur vietnam indonesien die
philippinen laos kambodscha und myanmar
diese region steht großes bevor
junge generation kambodschas hat viel
energie und sehnt sich nach bildung
[Musik]
um den wandel hin zur digitalisierten
industrie und wie die regierung sagt
elektronischen wirtschaft zu vollziehen
brauchen wir fähigkeiten und kompetenz
darum müssen wir unser bildungssystem
reformieren um die industrie in
kambodscha innovativ zu gestalten
es besteht immer das risiko manche
abzuhängen wenn wir aber gemeinsame
ziele setzen können wir ein inklusiver
das wachstum für alle erreichen
wir sollten nicht vergessen wenn die
flut kommt gibt sie alle boote
gleichermaßen darum müssen wir einander
helfen
niemand weiß wie asian in 10 20 oder 50
jahren aussehen wird ein solides
fundament schafft jedoch eine gute
perspektive
nun ist es an der staatsführung den
nächsten schritt zu wagen
das spiegelt die aktuelle führung südost
asiens die ambitionen der nächsten
generation wieder
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
die politiker sind nach wie vor
durchschnittlich 70 jahre alt die bürger
im schnitt 29
ich bewundere ihre leistungen in der
vergangenheit von ganzem herzen
aber es gibt viele probleme die sie
nichts angehen
jeder sieht gerechtigkeit und bildung
mehr arbeitsplätze zu schaffen als sie
sich vorstellen können
das not strong fortschritt von asian
besteht kein zweifel
das durchschnittliche
wirtschaftswachstum aller zehn länder
gibt seit zehn jahren jedes jahr bei 5
die verbraucher schicht wächst es gibt
bessere löhne mehr arbeitsplätze und
mehr infrastruktur
auch der online handel ist trotz
bescheidene anfänge im höhenflug
meine vision für südostasien ist recht
bodenständig
großartige infrastruktur und software
großartige regularien und politische
systeme
korruption und bestechung vollkommen aus
und richten bessere staatsführung mit
mehr rechenschaft für menschen und alle
beteiligten ein
und lösen uns vom politischen
ränkespielen und persönlicher ideologie
basieren wird sehr viel selbstbewusster
sein die zahlen werden uns bestätigen in
zehn zwanzig jahren wird die wirtschaft
von asian 13 millionen us dollar
erreichen
das entspricht der wirtschaftsleistung
von großbritannien frankreich und
deutschland zusammen
mit derartiger größe kommt das
selbstvertrauen wir hoffen dass
indonesien das heute 40 prozent davon
aus macht entsprechend mitwachsen kann
in den nächsten 10 15 jahren werden wir
sehen wie die jugend sich auch über die
grenzen südostasiens hinweg durchsetzen
wird und die sich hier viel mehr
startups etablieren werden ihr traum für
asian in zehn jahren
ein geeinter markt wäre großartig sie an
sich selbst als gewaltigen markt
erkennen einigkeit ist immer wichtig und
ich würde gerne einen geeinten markt
entstehen sie
ich hätte gerne eine vielzahl an firmen
die sich durch ganz asien bewegen und
asien nicht nur als geeinte sagt dilling
sondern auch als geeinte bevölkerung
sehen
bei
inklusion nachhaltigkeit und vernetzung
könnte sich der endspurt jedoch als die
größte herausforderung erweisen
wenn es darum geht unsere größten
gemeinsamen probleme zu lösen sind alle
leidenschaftlich dabei
die armut die sanitärversorgung die
ausweitung des einzelhandels in
bestimmten regionen
die einrichtung von fantec damit das
finanzwesen günstiger wird und darin
pünktlich bezahlt werden können
wir alle müssen die gleichen hindernisse
überwinden und die gleichen probleme
lösen
in sachen identität sind wir alle erfolg
haben aber auch unsere eigenheiten
[Musik]
es geht um uns und unser erbe bistum
unsere eltern oder großeltern zu
viele haben kein bankkonto der aktuellen
finanzmarkt lässt zu viele probleme
ungelöst
wie können wir das aus der perspektive
der jüngeren bewohner südostasiens lösen
das durchschnittsalter in südostasien
ist 29 jahre
wir sind südostasien nicht die über 60
jährigen politiker
wir sind die kommende generation
zukunft asiens ist hier und sie ruht auf
den schultern einer jungen generation
der sich dank schneller veränderung eine
einmalige chance bietet
[Musik]